en el vídeo pasado hablamos de la
importancia de la glucosa como un azúcar
simple y también hablamos de su
estructura molecular y lo que quiero que
veamos en este vídeo es cómo podemos
utilizar la glucosa como bloque de
construcción para formar azúcares
complejos gray o sea para formar
carbohidratos más complejos
así es que copie y pegue dos moléculas
de glucosa por aquí podemos ponerles
números a los carbonos este es el
carbono 1 2
4 5 y 6 y por aquí este es el carbono 12
4 5 y 6 las tenemos en su forma cíclica
y lo que vamos a hacer es explorar qué
pasa si este oxígeno de aquí que estoy
coloreando de rosa qué pasaría si este
oxígeno utiliza uno de sus pares de
electrones libres para hacer algo que en
química orgánica nos referimos como
ataque núcleo físico porque ay qué
pasaría si le hace un ataque núcleo
físico a este carbono uno de la molécula
de glucosa de la izquierda ahora la
razón por la que se puede hacer este
ataque el núcleo físico a este carbono
es porque el carbono está enlazado con
dos átomos de oxígeno y como ya sabemos
los oxígenos son muy electro negativos y
entonces están abrazando a los
electrones de sus enlaces muy fuerte
provocando una carga parcial positiva en
este carbono y por otro lado este
oxígeno también es muy electro negativo
y está abrazando muy fuerte
electrones de este enlace con el
hidrógeno y de este otro enlace con el
carbono y entonces tiene una carga
parcial negativa por lo tanto podríamos
decir que es núcleo físico ok
está siendo atraído por el núcleo de
este carbono y para hacer esto el
oxígeno va a compartir uno de sus pares
libres de electrones con el carbono y
entonces el carbono puede soltar los
electrones de este enlace y aquí pues
estos electrones pueden quedarse en el
oxígeno formando un anillo hidróxido
puede hacer que se quede así un buen
rato o puede ser que inmediatamente
después se encuentre con unión de
hidrógeno ok con un protón flotando por
ahí en la solución o tal vez este protón
estaba formando parte de una molécula de
hidrógeno y entonces estos electrones se
pueden usar para formar un enlace
covalente con éste jon de hidrógeno
porque en realidad este guión de
hidrógeno es simplemente un protón si
tomamos un hidrógeno
aquí tenemos un electrón nos queda el
johnny hidrógeno que es simplemente un
protón ahora qué va a pasar con todo
esto que estábamos diciendo que pasa por
aquí pues lo que va a suceder es que
estas dos moléculas de glucosa se van a
unir y se van a unir y van a quedar de
esta forma ahora es muy importante
entender qué les pasó a estas moléculas
así es que pues vamos a ver qué es lo
que pasó ok este oxígeno de aquí es este
oxígeno de por acá y luego este enlace
entre el oxígeno y el carbono número 4
es este enlace de aquí y luego este par
de electrones libres que se fue con el
carbono 1 para formar un enlace es este
enlace de aquí
y este oxígeno es este oxígeno ve acá y
este par de electrones libres ahora
están formando un enlace con un
hidrógeno que podría ser este enlace de
aquí ahora la única diferencia que
podemos notar entre estas moléculas y lo
que tengo dibujado por aquí es que este
oxígeno por aquí está enlazado con un
hidrógeno mientras que aquí todavía no
lo dibujamos aunque hay entonces para
que sean exactamente iguales deberíamos
de poner por aquí un hidrógeno y
entonces este oxígeno tiene una carga
formal positiva por aquí este oxígeno
era neutro pero compartió un par de
electrones libres con este carbono
entonces podríamos pensarlo como que le
está regalando un electrón al carbono y
por lo tanto tiene una carga formal
positiva
para que este oxígeno vuelva a ser
neutro pues nos podemos imaginar que
llega una molécula de agua con sus dos
pares de electrones libres llega y se
lleva únicamente este protón dejando los
dos electrones de este enlace covalente
en el oxígeno ok
esta molécula llega y se lleva
únicamente el núcleo del hidrógeno
dejando que estos dos electrones se
queden con el oxígeno y de esa forma el
oxígeno se vuelve neutro y entonces aquí
lo que nos queda
vamos a borrar esta carga positiva
borramos estoy aquí porque lo que nos
queda es que ese hidrógeno ahora está
enlazado con este oxígeno formando un
ión hidronew que tiene una carga formal
positiva y esto es bastante razonable
pero en términos de cargas no hemos
cambiado nada porque aquí tomamos un
protón pero después regresamos otro
protón aunque ahí no le estamos quitando
ninguna carga del sistema ahora una cosa
muy importante aquí que podemos observar
es que cuando dos moléculas de glucosa
se unen perdemos una molécula de agua ok
este sistema perdió una molécula de agua
en este sistema tomamos un protón para
formar una molécula de agua esta
molécula de agua aunque hay porque este
hidrógeno es este hidrógeno de aquí y
este oxígeno
este oxígeno ve acá y finalmente este
otro hidrógeno es este hidrógeno así es
que este tipo de reacción en la que
estamos sintetizando una molécula más
compleja una cadena de moléculas de
glucosa este tipo de reacción se llama
síntesis por deshidratación porque esto
que acabamos de hacer aquí se llama
síntesis por deshidratación síntesis por
deshidratación y deshidratación ahora
porque le estamos llamando síntesis por
deshidratación bueno pues la parte de
deshidratación es porque aquí estamos
perdiendo agua aunque ya estamos
deshidratando y la parte de síntesis
pues es porque aquí estamos sintetizando
una molécula más complicada
ok estamos poniendo dos cosas juntas
para formar una molécula más grande
aunque algunas veces también se le llama
de reacción de condensación
reacción de condensación
condensación
y haciendo esto estas dos moléculas de
glucosa logran formar un disacárido
que
para que cada una de estas glucosa de
forma separada eran un monosacárido mono
sacar ido y que es lo que la palabra
monosacáridos significa pues la parte de
mono significa único y por otro lado la
parte de sacar ido proviene de la
palabra griega sacaron que significa
azúcar ok la forma en la que se dice
azúcar en griego es sacaron el si es que
cuando las personas dicen que algo es
muy sacar ido quiere decir que es muy
dulce ok
sacar ido viene destacaron que es la
palabra griega para decir azúcar y
monosacárido quiere decir un solo azúcar
ok esta parte quiere decir azúcar y en
general el término sacar y 2 quiere
decir azúcares no siempre tiene que ser
un solo se ha querido no siempre tiene
que ser una sola molécula de glucosa
también podríamos tener dos a queridos
ahora el término sacar y donde siempre
se refiere a azúcares simples como la
glucosa ok también puede referirse a 2
glucosas unidas y además también hay
otros azúcares simples como la fructuosa
y muchos otros aunque también puede
referirse a un montón de estos juntos ok
entonces tenemos un polisacárido y toda
la clase de zachary 2 que podemos tener
también están asociados con los
carbohidratos en este vídeo pasamos de 2
monosacáridos a un disacárido ok aquí
tenemos un disacárido y hubo 2
monosacáridos involucrados en la
formación de este visa querido que en
este caso en particular es maltosa ok
azúcar de malta
cosa ahora el punto de este vídeo es que
veas cómo podemos empezar con
monosacáridos azúcares simples como la
glucosa y a partir de ellos forman un
disacárido ahora no nos tenemos que
detener ahí ok si por ejemplo
siguiéramos agregando más de estas cosas
aunque construimos una cadena muy muy
muy larga de esta forma nos metemos al
mundo de los polisacáridos poli que
significa muchos y la parte de zachary 2
que significa azúcares polisacáridos ok
muchos azúcares juntos ahora esto nos
pasó con los azúcares pero es algo que
sucede muchísimo en la química donde
tenemos una sola unidad en este caso la
unidad es un azúcar simple
esta unidad en realidad le podemos
llamar monómero les llamamos monómero
sobre todo si estamos hablando en
términos más generales y si tenemos
muchos monómeros juntos le llamamos un
polímero polímero ahora los
polisacáridos son súper importantes
porque yo estoy segura de que el día de
hoy te comiste algunos polisacáridos es
más estoy segura de que ahorita en tus
células
hay muchos polisacáridos no que hay por
aquí si tomamos un montón de moléculas
de glucosa y las juntamos de esta forma
tenemos un polisacárido y generalmente
podemos encontrar muchos de estos en las
plantas en forma de almidón ok un
polisacárido que te encuentras en las
plantas es el almidón
almidón que es un montón de moléculas de
glucosa juntas y además en tus propias
células para tener energía almacenada
accesible inmediatamente tenemos un
bonche de moléculas de glucosa unidas en
forma de glucógeno glucógeno así es que
estas macromoléculas estos polisacáridos
que formamos a partir de un bonche de
azúcares simples ok a partir de un
bonche de monosacáridos que juntamos
todas estas son super comunes en
biología las has comido el día de hoy y
además las estás almacenando en tu
cuerpo en este mismo momento